coke welcome to whack a pot would you  like to try your hand at taking out a  kubernetes cluster by whacking each  kubernetes pod one at a time anytime I  get to hit stuff with a mallet it's a  good day alright let's give it a try  alright  yes we have our kubernetes service up  every one of these first four pods  you're hitting is taking out a new  Gennady on as you can see system is  designed to be extremely resilient it's  going to continue to bring these  services back up while you try and take  them down making it very difficult to  actually take them all out you're  struggling that you want me to give it a  try I can't get them all down see if I  can do it  there wasn't that hot I don't want you  struggling cheater